welcome back to las vegas now who says
you can't treat yourself this halloween
beauty and lifestyle advisor don
mccarthy and pro makeup artist missy
lovett team up to show us some fun
halloween beauty tricks and treats check
it out
hi everybody i'm dawn and i'm missy and
it's time for our halloween beauty
tricks and treats first up i've got
something for the men
the women under 30 and newly released
this month on
october 1st from olay i have the olay
regenerist
ultra rich moisturizer this is packed
with all kinds of great things for your
skin
including moisture lock technology but
tell us what is this technology yeah so
this special shea butter blend contains
non-comedogenic oils so that basically
means it's not going to clog our pores
especially on halloween night when we're
wearing all of that heavy makeup or the
masks
this is a great product at the end of
the day when you take that off your skin
is going to be
asking for moisture this is the product
that you're going to want to use
i'm all about double duty missy what
else do you have for us so i've got a
great
trick for you guys the trend right now
is luminous glowy skin
so you can actually get that with your
current foundation so take whatever
liquid foundation you have
and mix that with the moisturizer and
you're gonna get a beautiful glow
i love that yeah and a super hydration
on your skin doesn't smell good
oh my gosh it looks gorgeous so good i
love that missy now how about a little
sparkle
yes please so from kbshimmer.com this is
a company that was founded in 2008
it's female owned and not sold at mass
retailers which i absolutely love
they believe that a little pop of color
and a little sparkle
can change anyone's mood and they've
come up with a halloween trio this year
and i love love love the names because
we're all doing our mayonnaise and
pettis and how we are
so first up we've got some bugs and
kisses yes this is a beautiful spooky
black with color shifting flakes and
they're micro sparkles
and what about hey there pumpkin i love
this one it's the perfect
jack-o'-lantern orange and again they've
got their flakes enhance the sparkle in
there as well
and you know me i'm all about purple you
are such a purple girl and we've got the
coulda had a bad witch so these names
are absolutely great and they have
everything from glitters to
multi-chromes
and kb shimmer really does have a shade
for everyone and it's cruelty free
vegan free yes and it's also five free
and lastly let's talk about lashes it is
halloween after all
so missy what are you loving from kiss
usa you know i love everything from kiss
all the lashes are great but when you
guys are out selecting them do not be
intimidated by how glamorous and
beautiful and long these are
you can trim them to fit any eye shape
like we do with dawn i have a smaller
eye so i always have to trim them
and then you don't have to be a
professional anymore to apply false
lashes because
they have dog's favorite product this is
their new lash glue liner
and it seriously is as easy as an
eyeliner you just slide it on
stick your lash and boom you're ready to
go i'm telling you this has saved me a
ton of time and a lot of energy
i have another trick for you guys though
to turn these lashes into your halloween
lash you can just take them and put the
strip adhesive on the tips of the lash
dip them into an eye glitter and bam
you've got glamour lashes for halloween
well i also have a trick for you too to
do with lashes
okay let's see this oh my gosh how cute
and you made one for me as well
i did i did so again here's another easy
way that you can just stick on some kiss
lashes
to any pumpkin and make your own little
beauty pumpkin for the day
dawn i love it you are so creative so
for more tricks
and treats for halloween and tutorials
go to dawnscorner.com to check out all
these products we feature here today
and we'll have more tutorials on the
website happy halloween happy halloween